hey what's going on is Bill Byrne it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday December 3rd 2018 what's going on
how are you how are you doing oh I hope
you're doing better than I'm doing Jesus
Christ I'm in New York City right now I
don't think I've ever been lonelier than
in my [ __ ] life good lord it's just
like you know I don't know anybody in
this city and he waits to [ __ ] know
everybody I don't [ __ ] know anybody
looking for a familiar face it's crazy
I'll tell you this city when you have 50
versus when you're 25 is completely
different so if there's anybody in their
20s living in New York and I know you
got a shitty [ __ ] living situation
like most people but that's your time
dude it's your city so [ __ ] enjoy it
Jesus Christ first of all it's December
3rd and I'm like oh Christmas in New
York is exciting you know I love the
holidays and [ __ ] you know and I come
here and it's [ __ ] it's colder in LA
than it is in New York I don't you know
this whole new [ __ ] post me to era
weather
yeah I'm blame blame too me too movement
on global warming that's my next [ __ ]
brilliant move in my career so I went
down I did a set tonight at the cellar I
did see Gary Gulman I was like oh my god
somebody I know and I went up I had a
good time and then I I left and I'm
walking in the rain by myself thinking
of like when I used to walk up that
sixth Avenue I used to walk up with
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] Bobby Kelly and
all of those guys way back in the day
and I'm just [ __ ] like Jesus Christ
where the [ __ ] did the time go
and then I was like oh my god now I'm
getting depressed I can't do this what I
so I you know I called my wife you know
I FaceTime with my kid that was all good
and then I got in a cab and I'm just
like I'm not I'm not gonna [ __ ] I'm
not gonna you know what is it whatever
you know you have like a [ __ ] sad
thought and then you [ __ ] just cling
to it it's like I'm not [ __ ] doing
that I'm gonna get myself in a
a goddamn mood so I came home I watched
a little bit of football and I watch the
end of the [ __ ] Steelers and the QI
Hodges
we got the charges the Steelers the
shacks and more anybody boss to remember
the MVP sports when they had the [ __ ]
employee do the commercial come on down
to MVP Sports we got all the jerseys we
got the Shaq's the steel is the charges
and more I watched that game and right
as I go to show it off shut it off and
said [ __ ] she's [ __ ] infuriating
it / depressing [ __ ] commercial where
it's the dad with his daughter you know
and she's getting older and he has his
favorite [ __ ] song which is the most
depressing thing ever it's a song of
regret I wish that I knew what I knew
then when I was younger whatever now
what I know now whatever the [ __ ] I'm
like [ __ ] mentally dyslexic so I
don't know I don't know how the exact
thing [ __ ] goes and then in the end
she [ __ ] goes away right so that's
the whole song of [ __ ] regret you
know what I mean like looking back Jesus
Christ I wish it [ __ ] you know I
don't need to hear that that's the
soundtrack of my whole [ __ ] walk home
you know and I'm sitting here and that
stupid commercial comes on and is if
that commercial isn't depressing enough
especially on a Sunday night they should
not be allowed to play that song on a
[ __ ] Sunday night at when someone's
sitting there and they're [ __ ]
loneliness about ready to start another
work week I wish dad I knew what I knew
Dan now what I wish I knew what I wish
that I knew what I know now that's it
when I was younger whatever the [ __ ]
song is then the end of the goddamn
commercial is the daughter's all grown
up now the guy takes her to college he's
[ __ ] heartbroken and then she goes
into her dorm room and he's got one of
those [ __ ] things you know you know
hey kunti play that song me and my dad
like and it's sitting over in the corner
just listening to her I don't like the
only kind of a [ __ ] sitting there
they trying to make all of this [ __ ] bug
in your own house hanging out with a
robot and taking a picture with it and
those Sprint commercials making
all seen like yeah hey this is all like
a great fun [ __ ] time or maybe I'm
just lonely and I'm looking at through
it like you don't - is I'm not [ __ ]
drinking either and I swear to God if I
was drinking right now I would I would
go to a bar by myself and that's and
that's how you do it that's how you
that's how that's the most healthiest
way I ever figured out how to combat
loneliness on the road is to go out
drink alone get shit-faced and then come
home and pass out and then you don't
come home sober to an empty room but I
feel like when I'm podcasting I have all
of you here with me I feel like for me
podcasting is like giving a part of the
world a hug what do you guys do if I
really legit I fell off a bike or
something and that was a result of my
head injury and I started talking like
that and I started wearing you know
those [ __ ] you know the fragile
chicks who wear those sweaters that go
over their hands and they're always
picking up like a cup of coffee because
they're always cold and they have to
hold it with both hands because they're
[ __ ] so weak if I became that person
well bill is simple we would listen for
a few weeks
and then we'd be like all right this
sucks now and then we wouldn't we
wouldn't listen hey what happened over
in England with the London derby which I
thought was like a [ __ ] horse race
this team that I never even heard of I
guess was up two to one against Arsenal
Arsenal Arsenal 1-nil Arsenal right yeah
they were [ __ ] up on him and then
they they somehow I knew they were up
two to one somehow they lost 42
everybody was losing their [ __ ] minds
pictures look incredible I wish I
watched the game having said that
knowing nothing about the Premier League
you know if you just look at both their
uniforms you know you're putting the
money on you know one of them looks like
a professional uniform the other for
people who lost that looked like a kid
drew it anyways so I just sat around all
day
[ __ ] I don't know what watching
football and [ __ ] I watch the Giants
very entertaining game against some
other team that I can't remember because
I'm [ __ ] old the hell are they
playing it's [ __ ] unbelievable I
watched the whole game I don't well I
was also cleaning the [ __ ] kitchen I
know it was an exciting game whether
they [ __ ] plate I will say this that
that's a quant Barclays it's good that
they're telling not to run so wide open
because he's kind of doing a little
Campbell [ __ ] where it's like you don't
need to take that much punishment on
every play especially when you're on a
bad team that would be a shame if they
finally you know became good and then
that guy was all banged up [ __ ]
leaping over guys and [ __ ] it's amazing
to watch you know then I watch the
Patriots first the Vikings I was
watching a who the [ __ ] is that guy
number 19 on the Vikings phenomenal
player I wish he played in our team but
on that fourth and short when Bella
checked through the challenge flag or
whatever and he's talking to the refs
and somehow that wide receiver got
involved you know what I mean to the
point you literally see [ __ ] Bill
Belichick he that guy I got to commend
number 19 on the Vikings he actually got
an emotional response out of Belichick
Belichick go and she goes shut the [ __ ]
up shut the [ __ ] up
said it twice and you know what I don't
know what was said in defense at number
19 but you know just sitting at home
yeah yeah shut the [ __ ] up you weren't
even in the play I can see if the
running back said something you didn't
touch the ball you barely blocked on the
play with the [ __ ] you jumping in for
anyways but the Chiefs won again so as
much as the Patriots so winning the
Patriots what they're doing this year is
amazing because we lost two of our top
receivers we lost our left tackle we
lost a running back and we lost one of
our top cornerback so this is like a
[ __ ] you know I I feel like the last
rebuild in the Brady Belichick era
hopefully we'll get under the
arrogant but I do not feel good about
playing the Chiefs again in Kansas City
come playoff time but they are the
[ __ ] Chiefs so until they get over
the [ __ ] hump but um I don't know we
shall see
we should definitely see and I just
watched the end of the Chargers Steelers
game the Chargers the Quietus nine and
three in the NFL nobody's talking about
him you know what I mean cuz cuz there's
[ __ ] the Rams are doing so well right
there like Eddie Van Halen the ramps and
Alex Van Halen meanwhile I was killing
it right behind him and nobody seems to
be noticed and except for charge offense
right with Alex Van Halen it only seemed
like other drummers like is it me is
this guy [ __ ] unbelievable and in his
own right kind of on Eddie's level
anybody else you know maybe you see a
couple of [ __ ] games behind actually
you know something I was getting right
through the podcast and I saw I went to
NFL comm so I could see a couple of
stats so I wouldn't sound even dumber
than usual and I saw there was five
minutes left and the Steelers were down
by seven I was a cigar I don't they got
Big Ben they're definitely coming back
and you're not allowed to play defense
in the NFL so why don't I watch this
video game here
of course the Steelers go right [ __ ]
down and bing-bang-boom they [ __ ]
score and you know you're not allowed to
play defense and there's a you know
there's a good minute fifty left and
then the [ __ ] charges are right down
the [ __ ] field you know but it's not
are they gonna score it so they're gonna
get a touchdown or a field goal I've
never seen a game end as far as I could
offside three times on the defense I
love that guy number 25 he's like [ __ ]
you I don't give a [ __ ]
keep calling a penalty I thought it was
kind of brilliant that he just kept
doing that cuz he knew he had to make a
play and then what did what did the lad
what it's on that last one he jumped
past the ball what if he actually
blocked it they called him offsides
again and then the next time he didn't
jump offsides then the dude [ __ ]
misses it then it makes sense I don't
know he didn't explain that correctly
but I think I think it made sense
whatever I'm just a [ __ ] lonely guy
but tomorrow night will be at Gotham and
you got a bunch of my buddies down there
so we'll be hanging out but uh Jesus
Christ Jesus alone stone sober in New
York City is is not you know that's not
what Frank was singing about when he
sang about New York you know my kind of
town New York City is anyways rest in
peace 41st president the United States
George Herbert Walker Bush you know I
was amazed at the amount of people that
like [ __ ] I wasn't amazed but I
wanted to see it
people being guys don't war criminal
right somebody said that right and then
somebody else goes show a little respect
the guy's a veteran he was on the ground
fighting with the troops or something
like that it's like you guys are both
[ __ ] morons he was a pilot he wasn't
on the ground
I hate something for you right now okay
but all the you know and first of all in
in a I don't even know what they were
referring to because he was a pilot in
World War two so war planes they talking
about in Iraq and Kuwait I mean I don't
know what's going on there I know Saddam
was our draft pick and then he went
[ __ ] crazy like a goddamn NFL wide
receiver so we had to cut him all right
in a military way I guess I don't know I
don't I don't understand how all of that
[ __ ] works but I'll tell you something
right now read this book called Flags
Flags of Our Fathers Jesus Christ if you
you know especially if you have a
pilot's license I just remember how
[ __ ] scared I was the first time I
had to solo well it was really the
second one I had to do the first one was
like round-trip was like an hour and it
was straight up and straight back I just
followed this highway right up and I
literally just did it with my instructor
and came back I think it might even been
in half an hour the second time he had
to put three hours on the Hobbs meter
which is basically the odometer of the
[ __ ] helicopter and
[Music]
that is honestly the most scared I've
ever been in my [ __ ] life and I was
flying a helicopter on a sunny day and
just to give you an abridged version I
hope I pick the right book at the same
time I read this book also about Eva
Jima but I think I think yeah Flags of
Our Fathers was the book and they were
basically they had this mission George
for the interview interviewed George
Herbert Walker Bush and he was talking
about how he was like a 19 year old kid
and how like you're young so you just
have that thing that you just think
you're gonna you're not gonna die and he
said you just would always think all the
other guys gonna get it it's not gonna
be me and just the fact that you know
any flew all these missions and if these
guys he'd be talking to you come back
and then just they didn't make it
and you had to [ __ ] block that out
you know they stood there talking about
ice and a field goal kicker I think
about this [ __ ] [ __ ] 19 years old
he's going through this [ __ ] right so
anyways they have this mission they got
to take out some sort of a radio you
know control center of the Japanese on
this island and the island shaped like
an old school football state in like a
horseshoe like where Ohio State plays
before they closed it off and the crazy
thing which didn't make sense to me
maybe it was that make sense it was
radio that would be down lower but
whatever the [ __ ] the target they had to
hit was down low right it like if you
pitch basically picture if you're flying
into the horseshoe right see flying into
the open end of the stadiums and you
want to go bomb the people right behind
the [ __ ] opposing touchdown end zone
I should say and what was crazy was the
Japanese anti-aircraft guns were
actually you know the way the island was
set up they were higher up than the
altitude these guys had to fly in it so
they were actually shooting down at them
and anybody who's ever gotten to a fight
at a football or a baseball stadium you
know if you're fighting a guy a row
behind you how much how much
of an advantage that person has punching
down now imagine this person shooting a
[ __ ] a goddamned gun at a [ __ ]
airplane you know what I mean so they
basically were flying in there oh I
skipped one part of it what former
President Bush was talking about how you
would come back from a mission you know
and he said you were so [ __ ] in shock
that you got to the plane like you
couldn't even talk and he remembered one
time getting out of his plane after
being shot at and [ __ ] and seeing his
other people getting shot out of the sky
and making it back he got out and one of
the higher-ups on the you know Admiral
whatever came up to him he said how you
doing son and he said he opened his
mouth and no sound came out and he said
and then that guy goes alright just go
down to sickbay son you'll be fine he
said you'd go down to sickbay and they
give you like two or three fifty two
[ __ ] whiskey and you do just do a
shot and he said the funny thing was
that it worked you know that's just like
oh the [ __ ] old school [ __ ] oh you're
just in a plane that people were
shooting at you're scared shitless yeah
go downstairs and go take a belt of
whiskey and then tomorrow you can go do
it again you know I mean I don't know
how the [ __ ] they slept you know all I
can compare it to was just flying on a
sunny day by myself and I just remember
afterwards when I landed and not even
after I rolled down because you rolled
down from 100% down to like 75% just you
know you don't wanna shut it off
immediately cause it [ __ ] up the engine
I just remember the greatest sound I
ever heard in my life was when I pulled
the mixture and the engine shut off and
I was just pulling you know the brake to
slow down the main rotor and I just
remember thinking like thank God I
didn't kill myself right and that was
just flying in sunny California and so
anyways so he goes into on this mission
and they're taking ridiculous
anti-aircraft fire because it was a
really important strategic location
and he ends up getting hit and he was
flying with two other people and he was
losing control of it and he tells the
guys in the back to bail out so when
they bail out he has to hang on and stay
in the [ __ ] thing so they have a
chance
so they [ __ ] bail out and he's
heading down towards the water and
somehow he regains control of it now the
little I know about a B I don't know how
he did it I don't know if them the
weight of them jumping out and probably
easily a couple hundred pounds three
hundred pounds just left the back and I
hope that God gave him enough and he was
able to get over the island to the other
side and then crash in the water over
there and all the pilots were warned
that the Japanese hated pilots they
thought that they were cowards um you
got to think you know aviation where it
was this was like a new thing I mean on
world war two they had like the biplanes
and [ __ ] but this new [ __ ] coming in and
with the machine guns and bomb and
people and all that they were considered
[ __ ] cowards so I'm having a tub read
the book the [ __ ] that they do the
pilots his [ __ ] nuts long story short
he crash-lands over there he sees the
Japanese boat coming out to pick him up
he's in the water he's 19 he's [ __ ]
crying he's taken in you know sea water
and [ __ ] and he said like a [ __ ]
movie as this thing's coming out like a
periscope comes up and a American sub
surfaces takes out the Japanese boat and
brings him onto the [ __ ] boat and he
survives his two buddies got caught and
endured like rediculous torture before
they were killed and in Bush ends the
story saying this there's not a day goes
by I don't think about those guys like
like what I could have possibly done I
[ __ ] something like that right so now
had I not read that [ __ ] book I would
have been another idiot weighing in on
this [ __ ] guy so I don't know what
they're talking about when they say that
[ __ ] all I know is that's one of the
craziest [ __ ] stories you know you
guys heard me read advertising I'm not a
big [ __ ] reader but I was reading that
book I was like Jesus [ __ ] Christ
I got mean I said I read that book
before I got my pilot's license I don't
know if I would have done it because I'm
one of those guys I saw jaws not right
when it came back they brought it back I
remember they brought it back because
jaws 2 was coming out and I think I want
to say they brought it back and I saw it
and I have never been able to be
comfortable at the ocean after that so
I'm one of those [ __ ] people you know
like I'll freak myself up my mind [ __ ]
with me in a pool and I love swimming
but there is time especially out in LA
where they got all these [ __ ]
critters and reptiles and [ __ ] that I'm
not [ __ ] used to and I always think
like what if some [ __ ] rattlesnake
just came in you know and it's freaking
out because it you know it's trying to
get from once you know it fell in and
it's trying to get to the other sits
already you know dangerous as [ __ ] it's
not gonna be in a good mood you know it
sees me come you know [ __ ] swim in
like an old man coming at it and it
doesn't want to die like it's gonna bite
me right in the top of my [ __ ]
Charlie Brown head anyways so I did you
know something one thing I did get out
of all of that cuz I don't follow
politics and [ __ ] the one thing that
they were complimenting him on the fact
that when they brought down the Berlin
Wall that he was smart enough not to rub
it in people's the Russians faces or
whatever you know I mean because we
easily could have lost the whole thing
who knows you know those are two big
boys going at it to heavyweights
especially now with the internet and
it's all like hey [ __ ] well maybe
next time but I literally watched I
[ __ ] pulled up a video right I was
trying to poach salmon tonight right I
don't mean to steal it and how to poach
salmon in the name of the video is
you're doing it all wrong and it's just
like why don't be it's like what if [ __ ]
would you come at it that way you know
just be like hey this is how I make
salmon some people do it this way I feel
like if you do it this way that you know
this happens
it's just like everything has to be like
maybe next time
don't put the book put the [ __ ] dill
on until you [ __ ] whatever it's like
Jesus
there's even hostility in [ __ ]
cooking videos like I remember this
freckled [ __ ] show me how to make a pie
crust one time I just read what a
hypocrite I was being anyways guess what
guess who has a new podcast everybody
the great Conan O'Brien he has a new
podcast and he was nice enough to ask me
to be a guest on it and you can listen
to it today I'm gonna be on it and
you're probably like well Jesus Christ
bill where the hell is it I don't have
the information in front of me
wait a minute with a hang on us now I
have to go find it hold on a second god
damn it bill how many [ __ ] times
Conan O'Brien I mean you could do this
too right O'Brien podcast Conan needs a
friend podcast on Earwolf com Jesus
Christ I'm promoting a different podcast
network anyways I'll be on that I had a
great time on his podcast and uh
obviously you know he's one of one of my
most favorite people in this business
like I've always said one of my favorite
things ever is somebody who's super
smart and they're silly and that's why
I've always loved him in handy because
they're both obviously really smart
people and they're silly as hell and I
had a great time on his podcast so
please listen to it it's actually really
cool because I learned more about Conan
than I ever knew just shooting the [ __ ]
with them in that hour so if you're into
Conan O'Brien like you should be check
it out there we go
also it's the first of the month the
beginning of the month so my patreon
page patreon.com/lenguin
new bind the scenes stuff that we put up
there we got a bill burr three arenas in
his backstage from all the arena shows I
did in 2018 me getting ready to go on
stage become an offstage meet jamming
with Conan O'Brien at the Forum Dean del
Rey Michael Devon and a bunch of other
people that's what I do before I do
those shows I always get together with
some friends play some music in the
empty arena so I'm not too freaked out
when I go out there later to new
episodes of uninformed with the teen
idol sensation from the Opie and Anthony
program mr. Joe DeRosa and we also have
I did a live podcast at stand-up live in
Phoenix Arizona we have the whole show
up there so there you go you get all of
that for five bucks and I swear to god
at some point I'm just gonna start also
making random videos for that I've just
been LA I just been really busy but
anyways check it out if you would like
alright okay now how long have I been
here 25 minutes I think it's time to
read a little bit of advertising year
did I even upload the advertising on to
here and I probably didn't Oh bill I
mean how long how long do you have to do
a podcast before you're a little bit
more of a pro and you're just a little
bit more prepared all right here we go
oh my god conan needs a friend that just
made me depressed and then I wish that I
knew what I knew now when I was young
good that's that's depressing me I got
to get out of this you know oh my god
should I go fat person on this should I
go buy a pint of ice cream frame bridge
everybody if you're a listener of this
show you heard me talk about frame
bridge frame bridge makes it
ridiculously easy and affordable to
custom frame your favorite things from
art prints and posters to the photos on
your phone now with the holidays fast
approaching frame bridge is the easiest
way to send truly one-of-a-kind gifts to
everyone on your list here's how it
works just go to frame bridge comm and
upload your video or the say
you a package to safely mail in your
physical pieces preview your item online
in any frame style choose your favorite
or get free recommendations from their
talented desires sorry the expert team
at frame bridge will custom frame your
item and deliver your finished piece
straight to you or whenever you need it
a completely handmade personalized gift
from frame bridge starts at $39 is
delivered in days and all shipping is
free plus my listeners will get 15% off
their first order at frame bridge comm
when they use my code bar I've used
these guys they're great I got a bunch
of great pictures for when I was in
France my lovely wife and my beautiful
daughter you know someday me and my
daughter will have a song and it won't
be something that [ __ ] depressing you
know
it's gonna be like it's gonna be some
sort of a tease can anybody tell me what
he says there but don't wait I'm gonna
actually look that up and sing it in
falsetto for you after this read but
don't wait make sure to place your order
Monday December 17th for guaranteed
delivery by December 24th [ __ ] I have to
do this because there's a picture I want
to get for somebody give your personal
experience using frame bridge calm I
already did it's [ __ ] awesome with
just a few taps on your phone frame
bridge let you create lets you create a
one-of-a-kind gift that will win
Christmas and make someone happy for
years to come go to frame bridge calm
and use promo code bar you'll save an
additional 15% off your first order plus
free delivery in time for Christmas if
you order by Monday December 17th just
go to frame bridge calm promo code burp
frame urged frame bridge calm promo code
burr you know as much as I listen to the
scorpions because they all had those
foreign [ __ ] names to foreign to my
ear I can't [ __ ] I knows like michael
Shrike nur the [ __ ] was the lead singers
name
lead singer of it actually poison I mean
poison of
[ __ ] the scorpions we all know Bret
Michaels I mean that's a nice [ __ ]
straight-ahead American name there Klaus
mine all right here we go
Klaus he had to become a rock singer how
the [ __ ] to get married married how do
you get [ __ ] laid with the [ __ ]
name
I've been married so long I [ __ ] I
just went to that I wait a second rock
you like a hurricane lyrics alright
alright it's a linen the Sun comes out
or the other reverse snare late at night
was shaking and pretty down my cat is
purring it scratches my skin so what is
wrong with another the [ __ ] is hungry
she needs to tell so give her inches and
feed her well Jesus more more days to
come new places to go I've got to leave
it's time for a show Here I am rock you
like a hurricane Here I am rock you like
a hurry they don't even know oh he says
are you ready baby he says more than
that Here I am
[Music]
he's got a [ __ ] in there you said
something else alright let's get back to
the read sorry alright well that's not
where they are they're over here
no Billy click in there alright tipsy
elves oh Jesus stay away before you get
me to everyone everyone needs an ugly
Christmas sweater this time of year do
you want the bragging rights for the
most talked about sweater at the holiday
parties then wait until you see it
sounds like nobody's getting laid at
this party then wait until you see tipsy
elves hilariously reimagined in
irreverent new designs stylish Christmas
whatever and just the women showing up
dressed like Santa [ __ ] and you stood
in the corner really like them [ __ ]
stylish Christmas suits for the
classiest of holiday gentlemen that's a
day that's a time gone by interactive
sweaters beer pong cornhole
drinking game darts so Uncle Bob can
relive his college glory days at family
dinners they should switch that to Uncle
Bill even though I didn't really go to
college I did but I commuted you know
what I mean
that's like it took a tour of college
you know and then you went home everyday
you sure you want to go there I think I
am but I'm not sure and even hilarious
themed teas and awesome cozy onesies you
know I thought onesies for adults we're
really [ __ ] weird but I'm starting to
warm up to the idea no pun intended for
women holiday dresses so you can get
down with your bad self oh Jesus i
catching leggings so you can strike a
festive yoga pose there they are
this Anna's little horse or a lounge
around with the cup of spiked eggnog and
teas that sleigh and cute tees that
sleigh and cute company onesies they
even sell bright crazy ski suits but
when you're shredding some gnar this
holiday season I don't understand what
that is you keep you won't find more
hilarity awesome designs anywhere else
so be sure to order from tipsy elves in
time for your ugly Christmas sweaters
now make sure you get consent from these
tipsy elves before you order better than
make sweaters all right before they're
triggered and right now my listeners get
20% off tipsy elves calm when you use my
code bar at checkout that's 20% off
anything you order on the site go to
tipsy elves comm enter my code bar at
checkout to get 20% off site-wide
discount oh look who's back my bookie
everybody how you doing I eat the what I
live on the hill sure watching football
is fun but it's more entertaining when
you got a little action on the game over
there guys you've heard guys you've
heard me talking about this for weeks
and some of you are still on the
sidelines and you better get off because
it's [ __ ] December whether you're an
expert or a rookie you should be betting
at my bookie if you're the kind of guy
that likes to bet a little and win a lot
like playing the numbers on roulette you
can create a big parlay pick three teams
to win if you hit all three you could
turn a hundred bucks into 600 you can
buy a lot of ugly sweaters for that
there's so much to bet on college
basketball in football NBA NHL custom
even e-sports you name it I recommend
these guys because I really trust them
according to the copy my book he's been
in business for years they've got great
online reviews and their mobile site is
easy to use sign up this week and my
book II will give you a 50% deposit
bonus to jump stats your bankroll it's a
great way to bank even more money when
you win how do you get hiccups in the
middle of [ __ ] reading also make sure
to follow at bet my bookie on Twitter
they personally respond to every mention
in DM not to mention they even give away
more than $10,000 in free money to their
followers this football season you'll be
the first to know as soon as the new
odds and props are posted don't miss out
on one of the best weeks to bet on
sports this year log on to my bookie
right now and use the promo code bert to
get 50 to get a 50% what to get a 50%
deposit bonus that's promo code ber you
play you win you get paid Jesus Christ I
hope you do better gambling then I did
read in that last [ __ ] sentence all
right last one movement watches MVM t
found it on the behalf that style
shouldn't break the bank they've sold
nearly two million watches worldwide by
bringing quality design at fair prices
movement watches are all about looking
good while keeping it's them ball they
don't tell you how many steps you've
taken or blow your wrist up with text
messages parentheses you up oh they're
taking a shot at smart [ __ ] watches I
love it they're not overly intrusive on
life with notifications text messages
emails etc they tell time like true
classic timepieces should and look good
doing it movement watches start at just
$95 you're looking at $400 for the same
quality from a traditional band brand
idea talk about all the things you can
buy with that saved money I could buy
some hiccup medication if you need to
help if you need help bringing the
perfect gift giving the perfect gift
this season but don't know where to
start the guys over at nvm T got your
back they did all the hard work this
holiday season she wouldn't have to buy
curating their favorite styles into
awesome gift boxes and packages
get 25% off today during MVM T's Black
Friday Cyber Monday sale with free
shipping and free returns by going to
MDM t.com / / movement watches launches
new styles on their site all the time
check out their latest at MVM t.com go
to mV mt comm / / alright mercifully the
[ __ ] reads are over imagine I'll get
a little blowback for that [ __ ] tipsy
elves once so please buy some of those
ugly sweaters okay for [ __ ] sakes but
I'm lonely you know what are you gonna
do sometimes you know the copy comes out
of different way I'll tell you right now
I couldn't I can't believe the amount of
[ __ ] people you know that walk around
in New York with their nose in their
phone especially when you're waiting for
a subway Jesus Christ like back in the
day you know it's you push people push
people in front of those [ __ ] trains
New Yorkers can you please get you get
you know you got what do they have that
a situational awareness
good lord they just [ __ ] trains
coming in there leaning against the post
just staring at their [ __ ] phone
anyways LA Chargers quite as 93 I
already talked about that what else Seth
Meyers I'm doing that on Tuesday I'm
doing the Jim and Sam show today Monday
when you're hearing this and yeah I got
a buy a shirt for that - yo it's the
weirdest thing you can wear the same
[ __ ] pants every every time you ever
do [ __ ] a talk show but you have to
always have to have a new shirt you know
that's why George another way George
Carlin was a [ __ ] genius because he
always wore the black and black you know
the black sweater with the black but
that was just his [ __ ] look this is
what I'm wearing you don't have to think
you know going Einstein with it so then
he just shows up and it's just like on
it's people just getting the benefit of
doubt it's probably a new black sweater
you hooked up like Mike the time on my
laptop is la time so I'm thinking why am
i dis tired at 9:16 and then I just
looked at the [ __ ] TV and it's 1217
Jesus and I gotta be up early tomorrow
all right let's read some of these
questions here for this week fantastic
cars and Oh second chills will be added
this week to the European Tour I'm not
sure what day yet just check on Twitter
and billboard.com for dates I can't
believe you know all these places I've
never been to before all these people
showing up it's one of the reasons why
I'm not drinking right now is because I
want to be in great shape when I get
over there and give you guys your money
worth alright I'm not flying halfway
across the [ __ ] globe to have a
mediocre set
halfway across the country y'all drink
you know I'll be I'll be a little under
the weather
alright but you know I feel like when I
go overseas I am an ambassador for [ __ ]
and dick jokes from my country
fantastic cards in f is for family oh by
the way getting back to that debt
criticism of George Herbert Walker Bush
and stuff if you see like just read that
book and I think sometimes you know
people tend just you know just see the
evil on one side whether it's just like
if you're overly patriotic you only see
your enemies evil and if you're overly
[ __ ] like liberal you only see your
own country's evil and it's it's you
know I think the theme of this is
depressing because I read that book and
it's just like I just cannot [ __ ]
believe human beings could do that to
other human beings and I know we're
guilty of it I know everybody else is
guilty of it it's just like it it always
goes back to that [ __ ] thing I saw on
the Discovery Channel at that time that
monkey could have just killed the other
monkey and it didn't it was a smaller
monkey and this one they first realized
that chimpanzees ate eight other monkeys
and in he just was [ __ ] keeping the
other monkey alive just and it was
getting off on the things pain and I
ever ever since that every [ __ ] time
I see something on [ __ ] TV about
human beings doing something horrible to
other human beings for some reason that
plays in my head and I'm like we're just
[ __ ] hairless monkeys
which is something Rogan might have said
or something I don't know how I'm
[ __ ] tired anyways not that clip he
might have used that reference but
anyways fantastic cars and f is for
family hi Bill I've just attended my
50th Car Show this year
wow that's more than one a week I don't
think I've ever been to a car show I've
gone I used to go to the car shows you
know showing the latest you know the
brand new cars you know nice to go to
that car show but I would like to go to
the I'd like to go to a vintage one
anyways I've just attended my 50th car
show this year so I'm starting to get
pretty good at identifying makes and
models of cars from all around the world
I post all my photos on my public
Facebook page classic and modern show
cars a you gotta check that out I'm
enjoying the third season of f is for
family thank you very much and I am
struck by what by the way that all of
the cars have been lovingly drawn in
such pain staking ly detail that it's
possible for a car fanatic like me to
identify every single car in the show my
question is whose artistic vision was it
to make such a conscious effort to
depict all of the cars so realistically
not just the ones in the center of the
action but all of the cars in the
background as well I know that you're a
car guy so I wonder if you had any
influence over the aspect of the
production thanks and love to you and
Nia and the kid oh yeah that was an
important thing with everybody certainly
people who were into cars on the show
because back then also you know cars
really looked unique back then and they
had a lot more personality to them just
because I guess I learned when I did
Seinfeld comedians in cars was basically
with all the safety regulations which is
great because less people die unless
you're an environmentalist then that's
not a good thing but you know less
people [ __ ] die but because of the
parameters of the safety regulations the
the area where the artist could tree
became a lot smaller so stuff started
looking more similar but back then
especially if you watch me TV like one
of the big things back in the day was
you know the star of the show if he you
know if he was a badass or whatever like
it was really like it was a big thing
what [ __ ] car we drove what car Jack
Lord drove on Hawaii five-o you know
what what Jim Rockford on the Rockford
Files
he drove a Firebird it was like the
top-of-the-line Firebird but he didn't
have a Trans Am and I always heard that
James garnets that this this guy Jim
Rockford wouldn't wouldn't drive a Trans
Am he wouldn't have the money he'd had
the money to get the really good one but
not the great one and and I used to
always watch the Rockford Files when I
was a kid and I didn't realize how much
that guy was struggling in his personal
life literally living in a trailer on
the [ __ ] beach never married and
knowing that now and being old and all
of that stuff and is it's like it's the
perfect car so the reason why and all
the cars are loosely based on you know
cars that were around back then one of
my dream cars that I always wanted was a
when I got older and I really got into
cars was a 65 Ford Galaxie and I always
loved the Ford the Wimbledon white and
if you could get that with that Ford
blue interior and I mean that's just
that's just a [ __ ] man's car you know
I'm not into the muscle cars I like the
muscle cars I respect him I liked him
when I was a kid and I always feel like
you know when you're a kid you know you
like the frosting better than the cake
and when you get older you're more into
the cake than the frosting or maybe just
so many I wasn't up to those Meachem and
it's just like one Shelby one Hemi after
another
I like those [ __ ] cars but at this
point if I was gonna go like a sports
cars and [ __ ] I just like ran I really
like random weird [ __ ] and I always you
know
I think I watched every [ __ ] episode
online before Jay Leno had a show of
that J's garage and one of my favorite
cards that he had was that I think was a
Datsun 510 and it's a it's a four-door
like basically a you know sports car
that Datsun put out it's really boxy the
lines of the car are [ __ ] so cool and
I remember you know one one of my
friends when I was a kid had an 81
Toyota Tercel and it was to this day it
was the smoothest shifting car you mean
it wasn't fast it was goofy was
front-wheel drive and it sat up really
high it was I got 81 or something like
that an ugly car but I just remember
shifting it was a 4-speed and just it
was like when it went from one gear or
another it was like butter and it was
this awful time where American cars had
embraced what they did with the light
bulb from day one with rather than you
know they had the technology to make it
last for a long time and they decided to
not you know make it you know design
obsolescence whatever they call it we
were doing that with cars and I swear to
God American cars would [ __ ] the bed
around 60,000 miles it was [ __ ]
brutal and the Japanese cars were trying
to establish themselves you know in
America you know and so they they went
the other route and we're really
focusing on quality and that [ __ ]
I'll never forget that so I was thinking
like I I would love to drive one of
those one of these days like I just
think you know it's a I also like a lot
of small cars you know I like those
bigger cars but I always felt like if
you drove like a big American car like
you had to be a big guy you know kind of
a guy's guy going to a bar and everybody
kind of clears a path or [ __ ]
respects you you know I just I just
didn't feel like you know it barely 510
like I was one of those guys so I always
like the always thought I look better in
a smaller car but I've also always been
like a truck guy and all that type of
stuff so having said that I'm one of
those we
guys we're I'm a Ford guy but I also
love Chevy's and I don't mean I don't
know you can be a truck guy not like an
f-150 f-250 and then look at a Silverado
and not like that or a Dodge Ram
especially back in the day because I
think all the trucks the internationals
and then the random dodge ones that you
see are those always cool because you
don't see those a lot so anyways each
character you know the car that Vic
drives the car that Pogo drives that
he's a you know he's like a caddy guy
you know Frank's a Ford guy Vic's got
the you know he's got the Corvette we
made it gold you know like the color of
Vic's hair and just you know cuz Vic is
basically as far as its kind of Frank
looks at Vic like that's how my life
could have been if I if I didn't get
married you know he knocked up his wife
is basically what happened he was gonna
marry her so but he ended up having to
get married sooner than he wanted to so
you had to put some dreams on hold so
when he looks across you know right out
his bay window he just sees this guy
living this life you know and the funny
thing is is Frank wouldn't have lived
that life because Franklin wasn't a
victim a killer he was a [ __ ]
relationship guy and I think a lot of
relationship guys their fantasy is that
they could have been a Ladykiller
rather than just accepting their role
you know what I mean like you're on a
team and you you know accepting your
[ __ ] role instead you want more
minutes instead of coming off the bench
where if you come off the bench the team
wins but if you don't even want more
well was that was a coach Riley the
disease and more so anyways I'm [ __ ]
you guys I'm half asleep there's some
[ __ ] babbling yeah when the kids says
there's a 65 Impala that bolo and Lex
have and I always loved the round
headlights on that thing and I always
loved I mean the impalas late 60s
impalas mid to late 60s and Pallas I
love those things I know a lot of people
like especially the West Coast guys the
rappers have stuff they like the early
sixties ones which I really like I like
the one
what is it the 61 the one that Lily had
a plane a jet on the side of it that's
the one that I like and what are the
ones I don't know so basically yeah we
try to make sure if there's if there's a
like a and the reason why this is a
great question because I haven't really
thought about this the reason why sue
Frank Frank's wife drives the the Ford
Country Squire you know what the wood
down the side is because my best friend
when I was a kid across the street his
mom who was cool as hell she had one and
I was just thinking about the early 70s
and that type of stuff where my life was
at there's a lot of real subtle stuff in
there there's a guy from last season
last name Linehan that was the last name
it's funny in the show the guy was a
jerk but on my paper route that it was a
great house like they were really cool
people and they always tip me well and
we just needed a name and that was the
first thing that I thought of so yeah by
the way if you guys keep watching the
show whatever questions you ask I'm not
going to give away anything you know as
far as story or anything like that but
just as far as like some of the details
but we really went to make the show I
never thought the 70s were sort of
accurately portrayed after the 70s were
over it always seemed to be more of the
way they did it on that 70s show where
it was like you know making fun of the
crazy clothes and the lava lamps and
which definitely was going on then but
like if you look at like like I love
that movie dazed and confused right but
the high school parking lot is [ __ ]
ridiculous those are high school kids
and they were driving cars from the 70s
if I remember correctly and the reality
is is most people like the average
person I think with their car be 3-4
years old and when when I was younger a
lot of them were a lot of older because
people just I don't know they did they
didn't weren't living the lifestyle
people live now or like something's
considered
three years in you know it's [ __ ]
two-year lease every two years I got a
new [ __ ] car you know so like in the
early 70s there was a ton of cars
leftover from the 60s I mean they were
only like you know five - you know
whatever 15 years old fourteen-years-old
so you saw a bunch of those and then
like you know cars from the 50s those
were considered really old because also
the style looked really different so
occasionally you know we try to throw a
car in for the 1950s like if you look to
its Sanford and Son the truck they had
which I believe was a 1950 or 51 Ford
f100 where the radiator was out front
just totally exposed and there was no
grill or anything on it and that was to
show that they didn't have any money
that they were driving that thing and
now it was funny about that now is if
you saw that coming down the street
you'd be like oh [ __ ] all original
patina didn't all of that [ __ ] but back
then it was just like now they'd rather
in a junkyard these guys aren't making a
lot of money all right that's one of the
longest answers I ever gave but I love
my show and I love cars all right
company raffle prize dear Billy private
pants I know what that means anyway so
the company I work at recently had an
outing where everyone from the company
was invited at the outing there was a
raffle that was set up where you could
win a prize and that's in quotes the
prize was a small statue of yourself
that you could get for free from a
different company that was hired for
this purpose I have to read that
sentence again the prize was a small
statue of yourself that you could get
for free from a different company that
was hired for this purpose okay they do
this by scanning your entire body all my
god sending that data to their servers
3d 3d printing your body as a three inch
tall statue and they send the statue to
your house dude I swear to God I swear
to [ __ ] god
if you ever bugged one of those
Bilderberg meeting
they are planning a worldwide thinning
of the [ __ ] herd replacing you with a
[ __ ] robot anyway so in total this
company would receive the following
information about you your full name
your email address your phone number the
company you work at your home address
and a 3d scan of your entire body it's
nice to know there's another thinking
human being out there there were
hundreds of people lined up for this
prize as I was standing there looking at
people in that line they were all
indistinguishable from cattle exactly
what do you think about it you know what
actually you know I think about he said
what do you what do you or he or she
says what do you think would you stand
in on our long line for the chance to
give away your soul thanks for all you
the laughs I hope this message gets to
you dude he said sincerely none of your
business
sincerely not your business exactly you
know what what if what if that's the
test what if the fact that you were
smart enough not to get in that line was
the test well wait a minute then that
test would be well this guy's the
problem he's not going to do what we say
so maybe she don't get in the line you
get whacked I don't know there's so many
ways to look at it I have no idea but I
just want to thank you on this lonely
depressing night that I'm having here
that you gave me hope that somebody else
views stuff like that the way I do
anyways female warriors and the worst
people when you bring that up the worst
point viewlet I mean doesn't matter
they're gonna [ __ ] get it anyway
those people just [ __ ] tuck their
balls behind their legs alright female
warriors mr. burr I'm a huge fan of your
comedy and a bigger fan of f is for
family the third season they had me
rolling on the floor laughing so hard my
sides were hurting I feel like you're
setting up having said that I think
you're a [ __ ] anyways which is a
compliment to your genius and comedy I
am graduating December with my second
degree in English literature the first
being in history no look at you you
smutty I bet you know all the words
there I'm writing you writing to you not
to show bias at all I'm just hoping to
pique your interest in history a bit
oh boy to get to the point
throughout history females have indeed
participated in wars
dating back to the Stone Age some
examples include Boudicca a queen who
led a barbarian rebellion in Britain the
1st century AD after she and her
daughters were tortured and had their
lands ceased by Roman forces that sounds
like a great movie though she failed she
in the end led over 50,000 barbarians on
a rampage against Rome and killed
possibly 2 million citizens sources vary
but you get the picture Joan of Arc
needs no explanation yeah it does I
thought she was in a whale's mouth
wasn't she another example I think you
would find interesting is a woman from
the US women from the USSR during World
War 2 a woman named lid Lai diem Lydia
mo Palo chinko Pavlichenko Russians have
cool last name Pavlichenko on to the
blue line Pavlichenko shooty skies she
got shot in the jaw and yet still killed
the enemy sniper and walked away like it
was nothing I just find it interesting
that women can be quite deadly when the
time calls for it I don't find that
interesting I [ __ ] I watched the
first 48 what you take on women who took
combative roles in history just hoping
for funny yet enlightening responses and
knowing you you never failed hope to see
more of your work and looking forward to
season 4 um I don't I don't know dude I
am I am fascinated and have nothing but
respect for anyone that fights in a
[ __ ] war but it it it blows my
[ __ ] mind that you can get in trouble
now for a joke but war is still legal if
this war is still like an option to
solve a difference of opinion between
two nations that it's like I basically
we're gonna kill more of your people
then you can kill of ours and then that
means we're gonna be right you know I
mean haven't said that all those stories
that you said we're amazing
I love these said I love that you
thought I was smart enough to know what
Joan of Arc did I have no [ __ ] idea
is she the sister of that guy who
betrayed Jesus didn't she end up in a
whale whale's mouth or something and you
know isn't that like the female
Pinocchio story or something Joan of Arc
alright Joan of Arc nicknamed the maid
of Orleans so a Saints fan he's
considered a heroine of France for her
role during the Lacasse trian phase of
the Hundred Years War
it was canonized as a Roman Catholic
saint he'll be shot her ashes into the
air she was born - I don't give a [ __ ]
what did she do
alright on May 23rd she was [ __ ]
Christ
oh my god this is just a few no wonder
you know I don't know anything about
this cuz I hate this part of history I
can never read the [ __ ] names Charles
the seventh week and what kind of
domination honey the unknown King
Charles - seven since Joan of Arc sent
Joan to the seas of origin Tina's part
of a relief mission she gained
prominence after the Seas was lifted
only nine days later several additional
Swift victories led to Charles 7th
coronation at realms like what does that
even mean and I have to look up
coronation this long awaited event
boosted French ride but she did
something in a war who was the one that
ended up in the didn't she get like
crucified or something captured trial
cross-dressing charged execution Jesus
Christ
that just make me think of Bruce Jenner
a truce with England trial there's a
trial for heresy
what is heresy saying bad [ __ ] about the
king I'll say bad [ __ ] about
Christianity it always goes back to
religion you know it's weird how
religion affects people some people make
some stop drinking other people it makes
them go to an island and gets shot with
arrows it's it's very dangerous you know
it's like some people can handle alcohol
other people can't all right I'll have
to I'll have to read up on her is there
a movie about it I'll read what is my
take on it uh well they say hell hath no
fury like a woman scorned I would hate
to see women acting like men as far as
you know going to war and all that [ __ ]
and then had them having to deal with
the nightmares and the [ __ ] suicidal
thoughts and all of that [ __ ] it's just
really it's this weird time right now
where it's like the support of the
troops and all that is to the point that
you can't really like talk about how bad
it is that these kids have to go over
and do [ __ ] like that and then somehow
emotionally try to get [ __ ] through
it and then this is the striking lack of
support they get when they come back I
don't know I don't know all of that
shit's the plot a depressing [ __ ] here
alright Father's will oh boy he just
somebody pulled me out of the [ __ ]
him Lagoon here hey Billy Bulldog after
trouble convincing my 47 year old father
to sort out his will in the event that
he passes away for some unforeseen
circumstances well I got to be honest
with you if I was only 47 years old and
my kid was going like hey dad you
finished that will yet I think I'd start
sleeping with one eye open if such a
tragedy were to occur now his assets
would automatically go to my so-called
stepmother
oh now I see you motivation who he has
only been with for a few years yeah man
he can yeah he can't do that as I'm sure
you would agree he would be unwise to
give this much trust to a woman who was
nothing stopping her from simply taking
my father's assets
for herself and leaving me his only
child empty-handed is there any piece of
advice you could give my father or I
could I to help persuade him to wisen up
and get this we'll sort it out as always
many thanks for the great work you put
in and go [ __ ] yourself I got to tell
you that's an uphill battle on two
levels one you're talking to a guy
asking him to deal with his own
mortality which men do not handle well
and then also you know that's his chick
you know you know how it is when
someone's with somebody that's hard for
them to [ __ ] see what you're talking
about so um Jesus Christ I'm [ __ ]
tired I'm [ __ ] bombing on these
questions I don't know I would start
playing catch with your dad
all right maybe while you can slip into
points you want to make while doing a
fun activity like that and just be like
that you know I know you love her I'm
not saying leave everything to me you
know what how about this how about [ __ ]
all of that and you make your own money
you know what I mean I know what you're
saying cuz it'd be difficult to see some
[ __ ] broad or only bang to dad for
two years get your house you know you
haven't said she's an [ __ ] though but
the way to go is to make your own way in
life that's the way to do it
just don't take over the family business
unless you [ __ ] want to and who gives
a [ __ ] dude
look if your dad's only 47 years old
even if he had you at like [ __ ] 25
you're only 22 years old so I mean I
don't think you gotta be eyeballing the
[ __ ] will at this point but I
understand what you saying that's a
weird one to bring up though yeah that
would definitely weird me up but if
you're gonna do it that's what I would
do I would go fishing with them I play
catch with them I would do something
where we were doing a different activity
but the bottom line is that that you
know trying to get a [ __ ] man to go
out and get a will done is about as easy
as trying to get a drunk to get sober
it's like they have to want to go
[ __ ] do it so I would use this as
motivation if you to not to get yourself
into a position that you don't give a
[ __ ] that your dad passes other than the
fact that you're sad that he's gone
forget about you know you getting his
[ __ ] bowling bag in the house and
[ __ ] all right boss his wife once wants
to [ __ ] me do I really have to read this
dude you know what to do
you know don't do it all right hey Billy
badass I'm a big fan of the podcast
here's my question I work in a grocery
store in Brooklyn Heights good I'm sorry
I'm so tired I normally don't say where
you're right I'm 21 years old and in
college I work at the corner store for
some extra cash my boss is a great guy
and he really likes me obviously I can't
work for him every day since I'm I've
got college and stuff but he always
wants me to be the supervisor of the
other guys we've been working there much
longer than me and worked longer hours
here's the issue my wife's my boss's
wife is a fine-looking lady of about 35
I'd say she's a nine and a half even if
she got 14 years on me he's really into
me at first I thought she was just being
friendly but she's become a lot less
subtle about it
yeah but hey chicks in their 30s they
know what they want they don't beat
around the bush they're on days when she
knows I'll be working she wears mini
mini skirts and sometimes a crop top she
stared at my crotch all the time and
laughs at my jokes I'm not a funny guy
Jesus Christ she invited me up to their
house last week when the boss was out of
town
I made some excuse so I wouldn't have to
go up there but I don't know what to do
here you know it's funny this is this is
a a this is a classic example of sexual
harassment that will never be [ __ ]
reported because now she's abusing her
position of power where it's like now if
you don't bang
then she'll [ __ ] maybe say something
bad you tore her husband maybe even say
that you grabbed her ass god knows what
the [ __ ] she's gonna do she's smoking
hot but she's a married woman exactly
not only that but my boss is a great guy
who's been really great to me I don't
know what my options are you here are
you know exactly what your options are
if I tell my boss about my wife about
his wife he's probably going to fire me
and I really need this job don't [ __ ]
do that on the other hand if I don't
tell him I'm probably going to end up
giving it giving in to her I only have
so much control thanks - go [ __ ]
yourself
this is what you need well she's never
said I want to [ __ ] you so Oh God here's
the thing just don't [ __ ] her that's it
rub one out before you go to work you
[ __ ] 21 rub it out twice and just
[ __ ] go to work put your head down
and just I don't know that's it huh
don't don't put it too far down go up
her [ __ ] skirt
I was just high in buyer that's it
she'll quit after I imagine she will
quit after a while although if she's a
nine and a half okay that gets dangerous
because you know hot women age as well
as former athletes to where it's just
one day that the belle of the ball and
then all of a sudden the cheering stops
and nobody gives a [ __ ] anymore and then
they kind of have to you know develop a
[ __ ] personality so like you by you
not giving in to her might trigger some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] with her but here's the
thing dude under no circumstances can
you [ __ ] bang this woman you can't do
it alright so what I would do is I would
continue to [ __ ] it rub it out twice
rub one out twice before I go to work if
you feel in a week and then I would just
I would be friendly
and then that's it and just wait until
it's like you're playing poker here
eventually she as long as you're nice to
her she can't get mad at you all she can
do is get frustrated and eventually she
might get so frustrated that she just
gives up or she puts the cards on the
table when she puts her cards on the
table you just say how much you like
first of all she's married and then just
talk about how much you like her husband
and how much you respect him and what a
great guy he is you know and then and
then this is a big thing don't judge her
either okay
like how George Bush didn't rub it in
the [ __ ] noses of the Russians and
just let the wall come down the big
thing in something like that is you is
to give her a dignified out not saying
she deserves one I'm saying this for you
do you give her a dignified out where
she can feel she can walk away and not
be embarrassed to say I'm totally
flattered if you weren't married I
absolutely would not to mention I you
know I think your husband's a great guy
and he's been great to me so I can't
okay and yeah yeah that's you know and I
would just you know something like that
and then just just you know hopefully if
[ __ ] goes away but I do find it funny
with all of this abuse of power and all
of this [ __ ] you know and I don't think
your situation is [ __ ] unique it's
just that nobody cares to hear it so I'm
glad you put it on this podcast because
you know I give a [ __ ]
good luck buddy that's a tough one all
right that's the podcast go [ __ ]
yourselves please listen to Jim and Sam
today and listen to the replay if you
missed it check me out on Seth Meyers
tomorrow and you can also listen to me
on Conan O'Brien needs a friend podcast
on Earwolf and and by the way this is I
think this is the last couple days you
can stream Paul versi special on Comedy
Central
dot-com for free so definitely check it
out and Paul broke all their streaming
records I'm so proud of him and he's got
some dates coming up so check that out
check out his new hour it's [ __ ]
killer man alright that's it I'll check
in on you on Thursday